la rébellion de la haute gastronomie
française contre la pression des étoiles
du guide michelin l'un des chefs les
plus réputés alain senderens à patron de
lucas carton vient d'annoncer qu'il
renonçait à ses trois étoiles que tant
de chefs mettent des années à obtenir
julia delage laurent debrot trois
étoiles dans l'assiette mais plus dans
la tête 28 ans qu'elles sont laquelle
miroite dans ses yeux
à force de mettre les petits plats dans
les grands à l'un sans drain ça fait du
restaurant lucas carton un des plus
huppés de la capitale
mais aujourd'hui en rendant ses trois
étoiles michelin ils cassent les prix et
son image
ensemble l'hiver avec des plus car ce
lot c'est plus d'actualité et donc c'est
à moi inventer une nouvelle restauration
soit moins sensible et qui seront à part
sur métro passe est mal fait pour
conserver ses étoiles le moindre pli de
nappes compte mais à 65 ans alain
senderens veux juste récolté ce qu'il a
semé
alors je ne peins je vais m'amuser et
puis qu'est-ce que c'est l'habit fait
c'est que ça soit bon à l'encontre chose
du plaisir le plaisir n'est plaisir du
plaisir et refuser surtout la pression
des critiques d'autres l'ont fait avant
lui il y a quelques semaines en alsace
philippe gaertner a rendu son étoile
s'est jamais un cadeau d'avoir une
étoile c'est
et c'est c'est un honneur avant tout
d'avoir une étoile mais c'est beaucoup
de contraintes
et pourtant les journalistes
gastronomiques refuse toutes les
responsabilités
je vous dit bon là on a trouvé qu'il y
avait une petite baisse on a fait deux
trois passages et c'était moins bien je
veux dire les habitués ça va pas les
décourager
c'est pas la révolution mais peut-être
bien le début d'une fronde si les chefs
cuisiniers déposent les armes la guerre
des toques n'aura pas lieu